ever I was supposed to chair the last
drop and I was also supposed to chair
the nine o'clock today morning top which
I came late I have an excuse the in fact
this is the first time I'm sharing
anything ever so I just don't remember
and also for the last talked I guess I
wouldn't want to be naughty chair would
follow yeah so this talk is Baikal we
marvel that you will talk about agnostic
there all right thank you so we're going
to talk about Gnostic learning is going
to be a special focus on mag Gnostic
learning of linear threshold functions
and functions of linear threshold
functions the big difference between
this talk and Adams talk from yesterday
that we're going to focus on finite
domains so will either the bouillon cube
or subsets of the boolean cube and so
let's talk about the whole bullion cube
cables first this is just a standard
definition of a linear threshold
function which you might have rebate
altea just says that if you put a plus
or minus on each vertex of the hypercube
you could nice drawbacks geometric
playing that separates them this is
probably the most worthy definition I
have in here so we'll start with that
this is just the definition of agnostic
learning which like Adam I don't want to
spend a whole lot of time on sort of the
concise idea is that we want to be
epsilon competitive with some function
class so we say that a function class c
is agnostic alee learnable with respect
to a distribution d if we can output an
output some hypothesis H so set from an
unknown target function T which we have
access to through labeled random
examples that the error of what we
output is at most well it's only epsilon
worse than what the best thing in C
would be so we're just trying to be
competitive with what C would do so if
there's something good in the sea we
have to do something good if there's no
good function and see that our algorithm
can just help put whatever there's
really no requirement here so some of
the background five mins or Donald's
video showed that if you've got the
intersection of KL TFS you can learn
them in polynomial time with for
constant K and constant epsilon and this
is for the uniform distribution on the
boolean cube the algorithm is just the
low degree algorithm which has been
around for a while it's essentially
just solve a least squares problem and
you're looking for a low degree
polynomial at the Sun bounded degree and
this is where the exponent comes from
and your hypothesis is just the sign of
the polynomial so it's fairly
straightforward the algorithms been
around for a while they essentially show
that this algorithm works for learning
this class now if you want agnostic
learning i'm going to wait a few years
four o'clock live-ins mass transfer
video to show that we can do agnostic
learning the same class and really the
big idea here is to do l1 regression
instead of l2 aggression of course to do
with this we usually use an l2
regression guarantee anyway but the l1
regression actually gives you agnostic
learning and while this result is for
the uniform distribution you can really
plug it into whatever distribution
setting that you want as long as you
have a nice low degree approximator and
again up to some small factors here
we're going to output sign of the sign
of p and so the proof here relies on the
noise sensitivity method this is how we
get things like the inline functions of
K LTS a little bit more background if
we're in the bouillon cube the influence
is defined as just the probability that
if we flip the ice coordinate of a
string that this changes the value of
the function we won't actually use this
Metro too often we're going to use a
related measure the noise sensitivity
the noise sensitivity is the probability
that we change the function if we start
from X and take what we call a delta
noise a copy of X the end here should
probably really be both too because it's
sort of a probability experiment we
start with some random string you might
have here how do we draw in Delta well
we're going to independently mark each
coordinate frozen with probability 1
minus Delta and so we might get this and
then anything that's unfrozen just gets
reran demised and some other things are
randomized so maybe we get something
else maybe we don't the key fact here is
this kind of ugly looking expression it
doesn't I don't you don't really need to
know all of the specifics of it you
don't really need to know much about the
Fourier analysis that's going on here
just that these Fourier coefficients are
the coefficients of F if you wrote F out
as a multi linear polynomial if you
think of F is an ltf it's the sign of a
degree one polynomial but it can be a
very large degree polynomial when you
write it out in
this form the big idea here is that the
sum of squares of the coefficients is
one and these multipliers on the noise
sensitivity here are going very close to
one half as you increase the degree the
size of s here is the degree of the
related monomial so as you increase the
degree you're approaching one-half very
very quickly so this is actually going
to be the key idea that we're going to
want later that's why we've got the nice
colors here so we refer to them later
and then the chain goes that if you have
low noise sensitivity this is really
with the noise sensitivity method does
once you have this then there's a long
chain of implications and if we go
through k km s where you can great any
questions so far this is just all
background nothing it all right and so
to start the chain off we can use
Perez's theorem says that if F is an ltf
but the noise sensitivity is bounded at
parameter Delta the noise sensitivity is
at most square root delta and by a Union
bound if you have a function of K ltf
then you can also bound the noise
sensitivity again just Union bound and
to get this exponent here we set this up
so that the right-hand side is epsilon
squared and this is what kk ms.nese to
guarantee that we really get agnostic
learning whether it's good approximator
in l1 and a paper 2008 where this
actually work in product distributions
to in a very general sense but we really
don't know how to do anything much more
than product distributions especially in
the booming cube case which are atoms
talk on law concave distributions but if
we're talking about distributions over
the cube we don't really know how to get
too far away from product distributions
or things that are essentially very
close to product distributions so this
work is going to extend this to
permutation invariant distributions
which was in the title and so these are
just distributions where the
distribution if you condition on any
Hamming weight the distribution becomes
uniform equivalently the probability
mass on any string remains the same if
you / mute the string so if string of
minus ones and ones you premiere the
minus ones and ones the probability mass
doesn't change
um in rebuilding hypercube case a
distribution is permutation invariant if
it's just a mixture of these uniform
distributions so although it seems like
we're talking about something very
general there's really sort of only n
plus 1 degrees freedom comments oh it's
good to note that these distributions
aren't even pairwise independent so we
are really I'm sacrificing lots of
independence here I mean in fact instead
of talking about n plus 1 different
problems we're going to unify this
actually into just one problem we're
going to just focus on the case where we
learn over the symmetric group now I
think these slices are interesting
because there's lots of interesting
problems you can do why would you look
at this well how I got started on this
mostly was on the kale theorem over this
distribution which I proved with
rallying back in 2009 and as an
application of this you can optimally
week learn monotone functions which side
of a long open question of alvin Blum
and others being related work because
I've actually been explicitly asked this
question multiple times on my put it on
here you can also do free to go to into
theorem in this domain this is analyst
work of myself I'm so if you were
thinking about that from KKL theorem I
can kind of tell you how to do this and
like this talk is going to use a
representation theory all right so now
let's get into how we're actually going
to set some of this stuff up we're going
to go from functions over slice two
functions over the symmetric group and
so what are we going to do well for any
time we see a string of minus ones and
ones we're going to convert it into a
permutation in a very natural way all of
the ones are going to get randomly
assigned something from one through K
and so that is a permutation so that
every so that each of the K ones get
something different 12 up through K and
then all the minus ones randomly get
something from k plus 1 up to n this is
how we're going to do this conversion
now I guess if we're going this way
would be a Kate it would be a
many-to-one mapping where the many is
the same always I'm so if you go the
other way it's 12 k factorial n minus K
factorial so you get the uniform
distribution over the symmetric group no
really we're just focusing down to
uniform distribution over the symmetric
group we want to learn some functions in
this space
and so here's our roadmap using the same
colors for things that we had before and
if we have time we would go through all
three of these things that we can do
these three things then we will have
agnostic learning in this case so we're
going to define what we mean by noise
sensitivity and we'll get a nice Fourier
representation will show that the
property that we need at the distance
from one half of these multipliers here
in the expression we get decay
exponentially and this is sort of why we
get low degree approximator it's not too
hard to show this when I'm sweeping this
under the rug for now and then we'll
also bound the noise sensitivity for ltf
specifically here which will follow for
funds in the LTS in this margin now
we're going to talk about representation
theory basics if representation theory
scares you I'm assuming you know nothing
and I have these rows up here they're
only going to be around for like six
slides then you will never see them
again so you don't need to worry about
them too much a representation is just
going to be a map from the symmetric
group 2 square matrices that preserves
the algebraic structure of the group so
representation just really represents
the group all the size of the matrix
here the degree of the representation
and we're going to sort of worried we
don't really love these representations
can be reduced so we're going to
consider reducible representations where
you can't like finally map them to
something we're decomposed into two
smaller representations and it you don't
need to necessarily know you're here but
we can actually get a complete set of
irreducible representations and this
contains all of the information about
the symmetric group and you don't
actually have to know anything about how
you would actually construct these but
just the fact that it exists we only
need it in the analysis we don't
actually need it in any of the
algorithms that we use so if we're
trying to get a basis for functions over
the symmetric group each representation
contributes degree squared many
functions if we look at the just the
function to the reals where we go from
the symmetric group to any entry of the
matrix and so if we look at all the
representations and take all of these
matrix entries then we really get an
orthogonal basis for the vector space of
all these functions
um so we get some very natural Fourier
formulas if you want to talk about the
Fourier coefficients which in this case
are matrices you can compute them in a
very natural way to reconstruct F from
its Fourier transform looks kind of bad
but it's actually not too bad because
this is just a trace of a transpose of a
matrix times another matrix so you
really can think about this as expanding
these square matrices out two vectors of
length n squared and then just taking
their dot product and so if you really
went through the effort of rewriting it
which is conceptually easier but hard to
kind of write you could just do it as
the sum of degree times a bunch of
Fourier coefficients squared or a bunch
of Fourier coefficients times Rho rather
and parts of all here is pretty much the
same like we had before I'm set that we
get this annoying degree term in here
it's actually not going to be too
annoying but it is going to be along for
the ride in many of our applications
here whenever you see a matrix norm here
it's going to be the Frobenius norm
which is just the sum of the squares
which for what we're talking about this
is really about the easiest thing you
can hope for anyway now fantastic we're
talking about the symmetric group and so
the irreducible representations can be
indexed by partitions of n so we part by
partition event I mean we're going to
take n break it up into a sum of
non-negative integer of positive
integers rather we write them non
decreasing this is what we call
partitions of n and so we're going to
get rid of the rows often and just talk
about representations being indexed by
their partition instead you can
visualize these as young diagrams if
you're playing Tetris with this that you
probably do very well if you have this
is for N equals 4 we get all of these
permutations here or partitions rather
there are five of them we just take each
part and for each part we give it a row
and each row we put that number of
blocks these are young diagrams and we
need to talk about standard young
tableau this really just looks like I
took these and drill in a bunch of
numbers but I get it in a structured way
these things increase from left to right
and from top to bottom and we have the
numbers 1 through n each put in exactly
once why am I telling you all of this
there's actually a nice fact that if we
count the number of standard young
tableau this tells you the degree of the
corresponding representation and just so
that on to check that this really does
work out the degrees here we have 1 32
31 and so the sum of squares of these
things is 24 which is 4 factorial which
is really what we would expect just by a
dimension argument everything nearly
here is working out just like we expect
also the young tableau tells you how I
polynomial over the symmetric group
looks like in terms of its degree what
do I mean by a polynomial over the
symmetric group I really mean a
polynomial over a bunch of indicator
variables that are 0 and 1 for the event
that Sigma I maps I to J I'm anytime you
really see symmetric group here you can
change it into something in a subset of
the boolean Cuban N squared dimensions
where you just turns a permutation into
its permutation matrix and then just
bust it out into an N squared length
vector a degree here is just the number
of blocks not in the first row so we get
constant function over here degree 0
linear functions are up in the upper
left corner this guy here is the only
degree 3 thing here and it's actually
the sign of permutation function is +1
for even minus 14 odd now let's get away
from these young tableau here let's move
on into talking about noise sensitivity
so we can actually get going on our road
map here so the influence of a set is
just the probability that if we shuffle
the coordinates in s that this changes
the value of the function you might
think about this is like the variance of
the set s with respect to this function
f so if we have three five six we might
have someone get some of the coordinates
but we're going to randomize overall
everything that's left from four and
it's three five and six there's a nice
expression for these with in terms of
waiting the Fourier coefficients the
degree here along for the ride sum of
squares gets in here we're going to
actually have to average these if you
try to do any
cific one of these that the rep the
formula becomes very terrible but the
average is nice this expression here
with the / k is the number of young
tableau that start with 1 through K in
the first row and this isn't obvious at
all but this is does take some
non-trivial work to get this expression
and again for now you don't really need
to know where this comes from this is
just that's better if you're talking
about sets of size 2 then you're really
talking about transpositions and a lot
of the stuff that we've done here sort
of implicit in the work of persi
diaconis from 1989 because you're
talking about just changing permutations
in this myth so we're going to do
something that maybe is a little bit
non-standard will define the noise
sensitivity this way which is very
similar to what we did before mark each
coordinate frozen with probability 1
minus Delta is that will freeze them
here and then we're going to usually
uniformly shuffle everything unfrozen
381 left and so will replace it maybe
with 138 uniform shuffle now if we want
to get an expression for this let's pick
the number of unfrozen coordinates first
and see what happens well then it really
becomes just the influence of a set and
so the noise sensitivity is really just
sort of the expected influence on the
set a here then is drawn as a binomial
because we're taking it to these
coordinates to be unfrozen all right so
then the noise sensitivity is the
expectation of this and the first thing
in our roadmap then is this expression
for the noise sensitivity again we get
sort of parse vaults identity down here
for the noise sensitivity we have an
extra multiplier in here which we're
writing as one half minus something else
and so we're going to hope that this
thing gets very small very fast question
so adjacent transpositions yes but the
on the formulas become kind of messy
actually so it becomes a little bit
different you don't actually get I think
you don't even actually get nice things
where you have the formula that looks
like this you wind up with like cross
terms and maybe even some negative terms
some things that actually become kind of
messy I think I wasn't brave enough to
do that
and so we're going to analyze this so
we're going to step one so step two
we're going to analyze this quantity
over here and show that it's going to
exponentially decay we're talking about
this ratio here and so we're going to
steal something from Okung capital
shamsky from 96 the fields medalists so
it's great when you can steal from
fields medalist we have this expression
here which say is handy maybe you don't
think it's quite so handy but it allows
you to prove this theorem and I'm
calling this a theorem and I'm
contributing it to myself because I
proved it in the paper everybody I asked
was not aware of this it seems very
simple so if you have like a reference
for this please let me know so I don't
go around claiming this they don't
belong to somebody else back as you go
as you make things this is the dominance
ordering on partitions which I'll give a
picture here for N equals 6 that as you
make the partition wider and when you're
looking at the young diagram then this
ratio goes up which kind of makes sense
intuitively as you move things down and
make the partition taller then you're
making the this quantity smaller and so
remember in terms of noise here we get
the minimum noise as we get things that
are wide we get maximum noise as we get
things that are tall again this
dominance ordering is just that if we
look at all of the partial sums of the
partition starting from the first entry
and moving forward that the partial sums
for lambda are greater than or equal to
the partial sums for bait we don't even
help q blocks in the first row we take
this to be 0 so this is maybe kind of a
non-standard just nod standard
definition because you can talk about
these things using skew tableau and if
you did this as like a set theoretic
difference maybe you wouldn't want this
to be 0 but for us we're going to take
this to be 0 it's a good question
questions
now the proof sketch is by induction you
don't have to do this for very many
exotic partitions you can actually just
worry about this case by a whole bunch
of induction and using the formula we
saw before you can handle this it's not
very not too terribly hard to do and
it's not too instructive to see and so
this really confirms that the tall
partitions are noisier than the wide
partitions on this other lemma which
really seems like what we want is that
these things are exponentially decaying
in this quantity here and the proof here
I'm not going to say is anything really
magic it's just induction take this
formula we saw and just manipulate it
for a while if you really want this fact
and you can get it out there's nothing
really exotic going on here it would be
nice to have a more calm torial proof of
this because you can kind of get some
combinatorial intuition for why this
might be true but I couldn't find one
and I just had a nice algebra proof so
I'm like listen um
what do you mean by the adjacent ones
I'm sorry you mean with like K and K
minus 1 and so the induction works by
like if you you could say that this is
at most this quantity times D lambda
minus K minus 1 over d lambda if that's
what you mean and so that's where the
induction comes from is that you
actually pick up this factor like every
time you decrease k so the corollary
then we will really want is the
expectation of this we can get something
that maybe looks kind of nasty using the
moment generating function for the
binomial but now we're going to use the
theorem we saw before to maximize this
expression and this is the expression
that we want i guess i have the
expectation outside here but i could
move it inside by linearity so let's
look at partitions or we're talking
about polynomials with high degree when
we look at their representation again we
saw this fact a while ago that if the
first part is small then the
corresponding representation talks about
large degree polynomials so if we're
looking at large degree polynomials here
we're trying to maximize this quantity
well it's maximize for something very
nicely just by this theorem here we're
just trying to move everything up trying
to make it as minimum noise as possible
means we need to maximize this
expression here in this case this
quantity inside here becomes d over N
and if you use approximation 1 minus
something over N to the N this becomes
roughly exponentially minus lambda D and
this is really what we want because we
have the minus D here exponential minus
lambda to the D so this thing really is
decreasing exponentially like we want
any other questions this is step two
you know how much you mean this one here
oh if you're like you're actually losing
quite a bit it turns out again obviously
that it doesn't matter but I do kind of
feel like especially when K is large
that you're actually being very sloppy
here because I kind of seems like you
know in the proof you get these factors
of this sort of repeatedly but it seems
like you could get away with much
smaller factors here so it does seem
like maybe you could tighten this quite
a bit but I don't think you'd actually
get too much of a gain in the end by
some of these people so we have any
other questions
alright so that gives us the first two
things now which is the problem of the
easy part because it doesn't require
representation theory at all is to
follow the noise sensitivity and so
we're going to talk about linear
threshold functions here these are
linear threshold functions if again
think about taking the symmetric taking
what permutations loading them up to
their permutation matrix will ignite up
to a vector of length n squared and then
it's just a linear threshold function in
the normal sense over this vectors that
correspond to partitions you can also do
it this way thinking about that it's the
sign of the weighted sum of indicators
of these events with some threshold and
also do it by putting the weight into a
matrix and then just directly using the
permutation matrix these are all exactly
the same thing so if you understand one
that's great is this in some sense
generalization of the standard well I
mean we're over the symmetric group so I
don't know what you would generalize I
guess
that answer your question so kind of
okay so theorem that we prove is what
you get in the uniform distribution case
essentially that if you have an ltf in
this setting the snow sensitivity is
found in very nice proof here is not too
long it's actually a reduction two
problems over the boolean hypercube
here's what we had before and we'll
remind ourselves of the Noisettes
learners experiment in a moment we'll do
the case where 1 over delta equals m is
an integer and so we're going to take
each coordinate and stick it in a bucket
with probability 1 over m uniformly at
random from these buckets so just to
make our lives easier all the buckets to
be adjacent coordinate we're going to
draw a sigma and then here are our
buckets of each of these things lie in a
bucket we're going to draw a permutation
that only shuffles corn is inside each
bucket so that the buckets don't like
trade any of their elements everything
stays inside is bucket so we might get
something like this doesn't have to
shuffle anything because we're just
picking a uniform random permutation in
each spot so this might be our other
permutation now I'm going to try to get
a boolean function out of this how so
whoa the top assignments to the bucket
will correspond to 0 the bottom
assignments will sign me aside one so if
I give you a string in 01 to the three
then I can give you a permutation using
these buckets so if you talk about the
string 0 1 0 we'll take this bucket this
bucket in this bucket retep 001 will
take this bucket this bucket this bucket
so we can then define this as a boolean
function where G of X is just the
original function f which we're assuming
is an ltf using the buckets the natural
way I'm hiding a lot of randomness on G
here G depends on how a signal is picked
and how this down here was picked by I'm
just depressing that for now the key
facts here that often go through quickly
is that G is actually a linear threshold
function in the boolean sense because
you can just look at all the hollow
weeks play here plays very nicely and so
no matter what G happens to be its
average influence is actually very small
the influence like we saw before when we
flip one of the bits
but the other key fact is that the
distribution if we pick a random string
X and then we flip a random corrigan I
this induces what we get from the
noisiest reviews noise experiment that
we want when we pick a random X we had a
random permutation here in a random
permutation here so like chunking them
together gives us a view uniformly
random permutation overall and when we
flipped one of the bits well that's like
doing the noise because this bucket was
formed by taking coordinates uniform
them with the right probability
probability Delta and so then sort of
the one-line proof is that the noise
sensitivity is just the average
influence the inside can actually always
be bounded by 1 over square root of m
and what we go and so this is Big O
square root of Delta can I apologize for
going fast them slightly over time and
so that's all three steps and so if we
do the same arguments that have been
that live it around since k km s 05 once
we have these three steps then we can
have efficient agnostic learning but our
setting here is the symmetric group
which we saw implies that we can do
permutation very industry so there's
just one final slide here I thought I
had something else you're effectively
the only ltf properties we actually use
our bounded average influence and that
were closed under some national
restrictions like if you identify
variables you stay in the class if Yuma
gate variable as you stay in the class
so you can actually do the same thing
for say ac0 circus degree tiep etfs or
any other class that's closed under this
where you can bound the average
influence and then you can learn under
permutation variant distributions in
this case with time and samples
comparable to what you get in the note
uniform distribution casing
I was us to make an announcement okay so
other groups so the problem here is
right so that we don't have any other
groups on this we use a lot of facts
about the symmetric group so we have the
index for partitions here but of course
you could ask the question about many
other groups so that's what I told
functions for this um I think that you
probably you can't do this directly
right but if you could do this directly
like you could you do want two composers
like very powerfully which would be of
course extremely wrong so they're not
closed under indications which must make
this work but if you write prob about my
friend fun is over this boolean Cuban in
the normal sense oh I guess what's weird
about permutation invariant
distributions is that monotone functions
are kind of arbitrary right because if
you fix yourself to one slice the
monotonicity condition is sort of
worthless and you could have anything on
a slice so it's kind of hopeless to
learn monitoring functions / permutation
variant distributions because you're
potentially learning arbitrary functions
so I was asked to do remind us of you
listed that geek Allah is going to teach
a course in wood
function starting today at I for 5 10
game soda 310 those of you are
interested to learn about boolean
functions